In the previous example, we had
a model where the result
of the first coin toss did not
affect the probabilities of
what might happen in
the second toss.
This is a phenomenon that we
call independence and which we
now proceed to define.
Let us start with a first
attempt at the definition.
We have an event, B,
that has a certain
probability of occurring.
We are then told that event A
occurred, but suppose that
this knowledge does not affect
our beliefs about B in the
sense that the conditional
probability remains the same
as the original unconditional
probability.
Thus, the occurrence of A
provides no new information
about B. In such a case, we
may say that event B is
independent from event A.
If this is indeed the case,
notice that the probability
that both A and B occur, which
is always equal by the
multiplication rule to the
probability of A times the
conditional probability of B
given A. So this is a relation
that's always true.
But if we also have this
additional condition, then
this simplifies to the
probability of A times the
probability of B.
So we can find the probability
of both events happening by
just multiplying their
individual probabilities.
It turns out that this relation
is a cleaner way of
the defining formally the
notion of independence.
So we will say that two
events, A and B, are
independent if this
relation holds.
Why do we use this definition
rather than the original one?
This formal definition has
several advantages.
First, it is consistent with
the earlier definition.
If this equality is true, then
the conditional probability of
event B given A, which is the
ratio of this divided by that,
will be equal to the probability
of B. So if this
relation holds, then this
relation will also hold, and
so this more formal definition
is consistent with our earlier
intuitive definition.
A more important reason is that
this formal definition is
symmetric with respect to the
roles of A and B. So instead
of saying that B is independent
from A, based on
this definition we can now say
that events A and B are
independent of each other.
And in addition, since this
definition is symmetric and
since it implies this condition,
it must also imply
the symmetrical relation.
Namely, that the conditional
probability of A given B is
the same as the unconditional
probability of A.
Finally, on the technical
side, conditional
probabilities are only defined
when the conditioning event
has non-zero probability.
So this original definition
would only make sense in those
cases where the probability of
the event A would be non-zero.
In contrast, this new definition
makes sense even
when we're dealing with zero
probability events.
So this definition is indeed
more general, and this also
makes it more elegant.
Let us now build some
understanding of what
independence really is.
Suppose that we have two events,
A and B, both of which
have positive probability.
And furthermore, these two
events are disjoint.
They do not have any
common elements.
Are these two events
independent?
Let us check the definition.
The probability that both A and
B occur is zero because
the two events are disjoint.
They cannot happen together.
On the other hand, the
probability of A times the
probability of B is positive,
since each one of the two
terms is positive.
And therefore, these two
expressions are different from
each other, and therefore this
equality that's required by
the definition of independence
does not hold.
The conclusion is that these
two events are not
independent.
In fact, intuitively, these two
events are as dependent as
Siamese twins.
If you know that A occurred,
then you are sure
that B did not occur.
So the occurrence of A tells you
a lot about the occurrence
or non-occurrence of B.
So we see that being independent
is something
completely different from
being disjoint.
Independence is a relation
about information.
It is important to always keep
in mind the intuitive meaning
of independence.
Two events are independent if
the occurrence of one event
does not change our beliefs
about the other.
It does not affect the
probability that the other
event also occurs.
When do we have independence
in the real world?
The typical case is when the
occurrence or non-occurrence
of each of the two events A
and B is determined by two
physically distinct and
non-interacting processes.
For example, whether my coin
results in heads and whether
it will be snowing on New Year's
Day are two events that
should be modeled
as independent.
But I should also say that there
are some cases where
independence is less obvious and
where it happens through a
numerical accident.
You can now move on to answer
some simple questions where
you will have to check for
independence using either the
mathematical or intuitive
definition.